how much of this is just all tied into
and I mentioned politics before but
really political ideologies because
everything you're describing really
sounds like the roots of socialism to me
and you're trying to fight it back with
the roots of libertarianism or classical
liberalism or just something about your
capacity as a human versus the system
that's just trying to strip every one of
their individualism again you know I'm
gonna sound horrible I would not cry I
wouldn't cry to choose socialism or
anything like that I think there are
different ideological standpoint here
well it's artificial standards it's
artificial outcomes that are not based
in anything described I guess basically
a socialist I think it comes back to
something that we were talking about a
while ago in relation to parenting and
the perception that you have of people
and I mean I guess I've never really
described myself as a libertarian but I
guess where I could be caricatured as a
libertarian is because I do think that I
trust people you know and the reason why
I like the idea of individual freedom is
because I think people are best placed
to decide for themselves what they can
hear what they want to listen to what
they want to read and this is why I
would be very much in favor of personal
liberty and I think so few people have
that nowadays and I think a lot of the
kind of safe space culture and the cause
for censorship from both the left and
the right come from this absolute fear
of people and lack of trust of people so
this assumption that if you hear a
radical Islamic cleric for example as a
young Muslim man you're immediately
going to be radicalized and want to go
off and join Isis but I'm really
interesting there's a couple of articles
in The Guardian in the UK today but
comment on what's going on in the US and
commenting on the old right and I'm the
can Breitbart
and they're saying that we need to be
more concerned about the impact of
papers like Breitbart and the alt-right
and the influence that they I haven't
radicalizing
young white man so these young white man
you know they sit in their bedrooms on
their own and they read these all right
websites and they're brainwashed and
they have no capacity to think
critically about what they're reading
they're just brainwashed and they're
radicalized and then they become
misogynistic and and racist and
anti-semitic because of what they've
read online but aha this speaks to a
complete lack of trust in people and a
really degraded concept of people they
think they're idiots right so on one
hand it's sort of there's a little bit
of both there because on one hand you're
acknowledging that the education system
has led let people to a point where it's
possible that you might just sit in your
room read some stuff not have the
ability to critically think so on one
hand right like you're agreeing that
that could be possible on the other hand
it's such a discount of what our
faculties consummate as people that are
what are sort of native ability to
figure out truth and and critically
think is so that's a really strange
place view but I am seeing this all over
the u.s. right now is this Breitbart
going to be the wing of the Republican
Party and trumpism and and all that and
it's like well there are plenty of
propaganda things on the other side to
this kind of assumption that you read
something and then you immediately act
on it yeah I mean there's been the whole
thing in the UK following the the
referendum that leaving the EU of you
know the leaf campaign it was all based
on one iseman and what's really being
said that is and all these people who
voted lead they were so stupid and that
they could not think critically they
could not differentiate true from lies
they they just believed everything that
they were told so it's the media just
telling them that they're stupid which
is partly why they voted that way so
they're really doubling down on it yeah
I'm curious so you've mentioned this
already but how much do you see do you
think that Trump parallel to brags it
really is just right there because I
mentioned you before I had Steve Davies
on from the London School of Economics
as part of our learning liberty
partnership and it was right before the
election and he bay
basically said frags have happened so I
think Trump can happen and that's why it
really did sort of get me around to that
that this thing was real and that's why
I do not mock all of these people do you
think that those it really all of it was
a confluence of basically the same thing
I think there's lots of very interesting
parallels that we can draw and I think
the main parallel is that it's
essentially sticking the finger up to
the establishment in both UK and the
u.s. you know we've had enough of being
told what to do
we've had enough of being told how to
think and we in the privacy of the
voting booth you know we will assert our
right not to be told what to do
but I think it it gives Trump too much
credit and it degrades the concept of
breaks it
I mean breaks it the vote for breaks it
I think was a vote for independence a
vote for freedom and the most important
point about the brexit vote was it was
not for any one particular candidate so
now you see Nigel Faraj coming and
having his photo taken next to Donald
Trump of chumming up and everything and
he's trying to claim ownership a breaks
it as if this was all his doing and if
it was a vote for him it absolutely
wasn't right he was a piece of it but it
was not he didn't get power exactly
exactly so lots of people myself
included voted leave to vote to leave
the EU without for one second endorsing
Nigel Faraj you know we did not think
Nigel Faraj represented us we did not
want a Nigel Faraj to represent us we
hate an awful lot of the things that he
stood for and yet still felt a bit about
leaf because the vote leave was a vote
for independence vote for freedom for me
it was about saying I want to be able to
vote out the people who make laws that
have an impact upon my life and I think
that's a really basic fundamental right
of a democracy if you live in a
democratic society if laws are made that
affect your life you should have the
right to vote out the people who are
making those laws and under the EU
we don't so but that said nothing about
what laws you do want to have or who you
want to be governing you or what kind of
system you do want to live for it was a
reaction against we want that freedom
right where is the vote for Trump is a
vote for something it is a vote that's
going to give power to one individual
Thoreau said so it might stem from the
same root cause there might be that same
desire to tell the establishment we've
had enough yeah but they're very very
different that's interesting because I
definitely think both were the fu to the
establishment for sure
but it's a journey because you describe
the the exit that breaks it exit as it
was a vote for independence I think he
said independence and liberty or Indian
freedom and I think a lot of the Trump
people would say the exact same thing so
you're saying the root cause is sort of
the same but but there's a real
difference in saying this guy is gonna
save me verse our system has to change
that we can get the right people in so
we can have that discussion yeah would
we want to Donald Trump Figaro would we
want somebody else you know that now I
mean unfortunately not now because we
haven't actually had breaks that even
though we voted for it right
you know the vote to leave opens the
door as far as I'm concerned to have
that debate about who do we want to run
the country who do we want represent us
what laws do we want to go for our
society whereas in America you know you
didn't have that option and it wasn't
there wasn't on the ballot box I want to
throw the system and we already did that
with you guys 200 years so so as even if
these things aren't completely equals
there's obviously a lot of parallels
here so my my next residue is you know
I've spent all out of the last two years
talking about how I see the left going
off the deep end here and it's really
been explained perfectly by so many of
the things you're talking about if we
were to look at the left in Britain
since Briggs it did they have they taken
a look at themselves how they looked in
the mirror or have they just double down
because I suspect our left here is only
going to get further left I think it's
gonna get more violent I think they're
gonna put more where you would argue are
unjust or on or foolish protest etcetera
etcetera so they do they do any of that
was there any of nothing
I wish I wish now it's really
interesting because obviously the vote
leave the for the year vote leave one I
mean we didn't win by a huge margin but
it did win now the Labour Party came out
Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the Labour
Party admittedly late in the day
admittedly reluctantly but he came out
in favor of remain and then he argued
for remain and you know he everybody
knew it was a kind of open secret in the
country that Jeremy Corbyn wasn't really
that enthusiastic about remain angry you
that he actually was by instinct
somebody who wanted to leave the you you
why would someone that's on the left
like Corbin want to leave though if he
wants if he's okay with more state power
as a general rule but I mean this is why
you can get into the history of the left
and I mean I'm very definite I mean I
joined the Revolutionary Communist Party
when I was at university you know I'm
somebody who comes from a left tradition
but you know when I was very passionate
about being a revolutionary communist it
was not because I wanted so much more
state control I still believed in all
the things about freedom and liberty and
free speech that I believe in now but
those things weren't seen as being
opposite to left-wing views it was not
seen as being this huge contradiction
and the thing that kind of really upsets
me nowadays is it's almost as if the
political right has taken ownership of
all things like free speech and academic
freedom and you have to really make the
case to people that arguing for freedom
and arguing for academic freedom free
speech on campus and not inherently
right wing's know their their liberal
principles classical liberal principles
but we I guess the let we've just failed
yes we've just been I mean they they
were I mean the same with with kind of
economic progress or you know wanting to
build new houses bill Runway is filled
infrastructure in your country progress
you know that was at one point not a
million miles away from what the left
was arguing so
left is completely transformed so Jeremy
Corbyn I think he's much more of a kin
to kind of Bernie Sanders figure in the
US and he's from that type of generation
so tony benn was another kind of hero of
the left and dead now where these people
came from a tradition where they did
have some skepticism about the year you
you know where they did have some belief
in human freedom but and sovereignty and
democracy but now they're kind of made
to seem like relics of a bygone era
there seem to like old and you know that
there's a bit of a cult around Corbin
for many people but the ideas that they
propagate I kind of seen by all the PR
types now who surround biloba party as
being too dangerous to out there you
know won't win the vote so you've got to
rein it in you've got to argue something
different so Corbin came out late in the
day and argued this remain position they
lost so you think then it would be a
good opportunity for him to stand up and
say well I didn't believe in that anyway
you know really this was my position
this was what I wanted to argue but no
so you've got the Liberal Democrats I'm
very very ironically named party and
you've got the Labour Party in the UK
who you know seemed absolutely
determined how to argue either for a
second referendum or to argue to water
down right the brexit so they don't like
the results of an absolutely Democrat I
mean it really is there's so many
parallels here absolutely and you know
if they wanted to connect with the
people to me it would seem like the
logical thing to do to have that period
of reflection to step back to think you
know why are we so out of kilter and
again you know you see this completely
in academia so they did a poll of
academics before the referendum and 90%
9 0 % of academics we're going to vote
remain and obviously then they lost yeah
so you see two things you see how on the
one hand how this kind of real chasm
that's opening up between what I could M
extinct what members of the Labour Party
think and what the general public thinks
and also there's kind of real
homogeneity within academia
and within the Labor Party they all
think the same and they all think
something different to what everyone
else is thinking so I'm gonna try to
spin this positively feeling you might
be able to fix me here but isn't in some
ways this is the greatest strength of
our democracies for Britain and for the
United States that all the establishment
the media the elites the people with
money the power all that could want
something and the people in our two
countries said we want something else
now now ultimately maybe brexit will be
a bad move maybe the Trump presidency
will be a bad move but that almost
everyone in the rest of the world would
be incredibly jealous of the power that
we wield over the people who control us
and general you're absolutely right and
that's what gets me out of bed in the
morning because that's so exciting that
possibility that opportunity that you
can change the world and but the problem
is you know people have got this amazing
power and it's so wonderful and I think
it really should be celebrated come New
Year's Eve you know I'll be having a
glass of champagne and saying hooray
these things because I think 2016 should
go down in history as the yaar
that people stood up to these elites and
showed them know we've had enough we
want democracy we want to have a say in
how our lives are governed and we don't
like the way you're you're taking us and
I think that's absolutely glorious and
absolutely something that should be
celebrated but yeah and you can see then
side described students as having a
temper tantrum right I mean I think this
is them what you're getting from the the
elite in the media and academics and the
political establishment is this kind of
temper tantrum then and you think if it
was any degree of rationality there
would be this step back this period of
reflection where did we go wrong you
know what why have we grown so distant
why has this gap opened up but they
can't do that they can't get beyond the
toddler tantrum yeah it's just hurl
abuse you know you're all sexist you're
all racist you're homophobic your homes
not working anymore and it's not working
and that's why wouldn't it be crazy to
think of 10 years ago if someone would
have said to you you know the way that
your
side your political philosophy is gonna
get a win is by britain leaving the you
would you thought they were crazy
probably 10 years ago i don't know i
mean i i i i think the i don't think we
were even having those discussions 10
years ago right so the idea of it would
have been insane said well that's a
crazy idea because for me it's like if
someone would have said to me ten years
ago the way that the social justice
worries in this machine and the elites
and all that would get would get their
first loss in a long time their first
major loss would be if Trump was
president I would go for some the Trump
being president would be nuts I mean
I'll go you're you're bonkers mmm-hmm
and yet even though I didn't support
Trump here we are I see a great
opportunity here absolutely and I think
the thing that's really interesting is
how on both sides of the Atlantic the
posters have got it wrong have got it so
so wrong and I think there's two things
going on there I think you create this
climate and I was speaking to people in
San Diego yesterday at one of these anti
Trump protests and so this guy said to
me or you know he voted Trump he said my
dad's told me not to tell anyone that
says dad what's that next time you know
that these people they can get nasty if
you tell them and respectable woman as
well he said well I was independent and
it's only later I thought oh you know I
wonder if she's saying independent
because she doesn't want to come out and
say she voted for Trump so when you get
this kind of response from academia
media you know political elite you
create this climate where people don't
want to say who they're going to vote
for they they feel they can't say out
loud and so putting that cross in the
voting booth becomes it's complete act
of rebellion so I think that makes it
harder for the posters to predict how
things are gonna go because people just
won't say why should they you know they
don't have to do but people just won't
say but but you know the left needs to
look at itself why have they created
this climb that the censorious
moralistic climate where people won't
say who they're going to vote for but
then I think the other thing that's
going on is the pollsters are so much a
part of this bubble there and just so
much just have their own
reflect back to them that they are
incredulous that people can think
differently so when they take these
polls and it comes back oh you know
people are going to vote remain and
people are going to vote for Hillary
they believe them because that's what
they think the others yeah so they don't
go beyond that they don't question what
people really think yeah you've got this
kind of growing gap yeah well on that
note I think this is actually all been
framed in sort of there was sort of
there's sort of depressing state of
what's happening here but but a hopeful
future because some of this stuff is
being unfurled and people like you are
out there talking about it well I think
it does it creates a really good
opportunity for people to say let's go
and you know the futures are always
essentially you know we need to convince
to take people seriously I think that's
really important to take people
seriously and win people over with
arguments not just through crying and
banning things but actually have proper
arguments with people rational political
debate and assume that people are
capable of engaging in that rational
political debate and you can't just hurl
insults and cry and people and expect
them to change their minds that way but
it means that if you do take people
seriously you do engage in debate with
people it's also play for yeah they
might say some things you disagree with
and you got to be okay with that - well
I always say if I don't look down once
it's good interview I did not look at
those ones so thank you so much I want
to thank my guest Joanna Williams and
our partner learn Liberty for sending
her our way you can follow Joanna on
Twitter it's at Jo Jo Williams - 9-3
thanks and thanks to Larry King and all
the or our team by the way and we'll do
it again next week